folks I don't need to tell you how good
God of War Ragnarok looks you've seen
the trailers you've seen the game play
what I'm here to tell you is how to
truly appreciate ragnarok's visuals and
all its glorious and godly detail the
secret play in immersive mode that's
right playing God of War without a HUD
might seem a bit ridiculous but Ragnarok
like 2018's God of War was designed with
immersive mode in mind at least to some
extent it's more challenging but if
you're a glutton for punishment Like
Yours Truly then it might just be the
best way to play so let's start at the
beginning you can turn on immersive mode
from the HUD settings in the pause menu
there are actually a few options here
default immersive and hidden the fall
gives you the standard HUD immersive
turns off the HUD but with the swipe of
a touchpad critical information will
populate the screen hidden removes the
HUD altogether if you're feeling really
confident you can hide the HUD entirely
however in my experience I prefer to
have it easily accessible just in case
send you to check the compass
occasionally you may also want to check
on a boss's health bar because some
battles can be quite long so what
information are you missing out on by
turning on immersive mode well you can't
see kratos's health bar enemy health
bars enemy levels the enemy indicator
kratos's rage meter the compass
companion information including atreus's
Arrow count and text pop-ups in theory
immersive mode removes all the
extraneous HUD elements so you can focus
on the oh so brutal action in front of
you
oh
not seeing kratos's health bar isn't as
much of a problem as it may seem when
that red vignette starts to appear your
health is low either make some distance
between you and your enemies or look for
some green crystals to heal up if you've
been keeping Kratos well equipped you
might be able to take a few lighter hits
when that red vignette appears but I
wouldn't take too many chances no enemy
health bars are a little bit tougher to
get used to though especially when
fighting tankier enemies for most
standard enemies there aren't any tells
that a foe is getting weak this means
you have to hack at them until the red
finisher ring pops up or they just die
speaking of finishers you also can't see
an enemy stagger meter this means that
if you want to use a finisher you need
to focus your aggression on a specific
enemy until you see that red ring just
be ready to click the right stick when
that red ring appears without the
Stagger meter it can sometimes appear
out of nowhere especially for boss
fights the ring does linger for a bit
however if you're too caught up in your
ax swinging you might kill the enemy too
quickly
thankfully even in immersive mode you
can still see the attack Rings tied to
specific enemy moves the red circle
still means it's unblockable yellow
means you'll get staggered if you don't
counter and blue means you can Shield
break an enemy responding to these cues
properly is crucial in immersive mode
this is the only non-diegetic
information immersive mode gives you so
make sure to take advantage of these
moments whenever possible
now one of the coolest things about
immersive mode is that because you don't
have an enemy indicator watching your
back you need to listen to your
companions when enemies approach from
behind this happened in 2018 as well but
it's far more reliable in Ragnarok
atreus or mamir will accurately make
callouts in basically every combat
scenario
it makes sense given that mimir is
basically the eyes in the back of
kratos's head or but I guess even if
immersive mode doesn't sound like your
thing I'd still recommend turning off
the enemy indicator relying on your
companions to have your back rather than
a little arrow gives your friends more
agency and makes the experience a little
more authentic not being able to see
kratos's rage meter also makes immersive
mode a tad more tricky once again
there's no visual indicator when
kratos's rage is full so it's impossible
to know when you should use it I
typically save rage for a tricky fight
or a boss and in my experience this has
worked pretty well I'm definitely not as
efficient with my rage as I would be if
I played with the default HUD but you
can't have it all
oh
bro
as I mentioned before the compass is the
main reason why I don't recommend
turning off the HUD altogether while I
wouldn't consider God of War Ragnarok an
open world game there are still a lot of
open areas that you might get lost in
being able to mark something on the map
and swipe a touchpad to see the compass
saves a ton of time I guess if you
really want to play with the HUD hidden
you could reference your map whenever
you get lost but continually flipping
back and forth got pretty distracting
for me especially when I was just trying
to knock out some simple side quests
along with everything else you will also
lose your companion information in the
bottom right corner this tracks how many
arrows of Trace can fire and the
cooldown on his ability fortunately I
don't think you really need this
information if you press square and he
doesn't fire off an arrow then you just
need to give him a few seconds typically
atreus's ability takes a long time to
recharge so I just use that once per
fight and leave it at that
everything
biggest downside of immersive mode is
that text pop-ups don't appear even if
you swipe to reveal the HUD this means
that you probably won't know what Kratos
picks up unless you check the menu with
hack silver and crafting components this
isn't as much of an issue I just assume
that it will help me craft whenever I
return to Brock and syndrome but it also
means you won't get any details on the
Collectibles you pick up during your
adventure you can always check that
stuff out in the menu but I do wish I
could at least know what some of the
stuff I'm finding is called okay so
that's how you play God of War Ragnarok
with immersive mode turned on let's talk
about the why obviously you can and
should play Ragnarok any way you see fit
it is an excellent game no matter how
you play it and this time around there's
a whole Suite of accessibility options
at your disposal go wild especially in
the early hours however immersive mode
really stands out because it forces you
to find a rhythm to combat on your own
without a HUD to rely on this means
you'll have to pay attention to your
surroundings focus on the Fantastic
sound design and work together with your
companions to a higher degree sure the
game isn't perfect for completely
hudless playthroughs but it's pretty
damn close the world Sony Santa Monica
has created is Rich with detail and all
too easy to get lost in playing with
immersive mode just removes one more
barrier from that experience anyway let
me know what you think do you plan on
trying immersive mode or will you stick
to the default settings for more on God
of War Ragnarok stay tuned to GameSpot